hey guys it's Tuesday and yesterday I
learned two hard lessons never put a
napkin in with your wash and watch that
where you're going otherwise you walk
into a park bench last night PlayStation
held their TGS press conference and
Square Enix had a bunch of cool stuff to
share Square Enix announced a new game
left alive that veteran Metal Gear
illustrator Yoji Shinkawa is working on
we don't know much about this one but
look at that artwork dang there's other
big names attached to this one including
producer Shinji Hashimoto who has worked
on Final Fantasy in Kingdom Hearts and
Toshi Fumi nabeshima the director of the
armored Corps series also on the stream
it was announced that Final Fantasy 9 is
coming to ps4 and what's more it's
available right now so I guess
technically it's come to be as well and
it's discounted that's right you can
grab it from the PlayStation Store for
21 bucks if you're so inclined and if
you're a PlayStation Plus member you'll
get an extra 20% off pretty pretty cheap
the big news from Playstations TGS
conference didn't stop there though as
we also got a release date and a brand
new trailer for Monster Hunter World the
new Monster Hunter entry will arrive on
ps4 and Xbox one on January 26th of the
next year for those waiting to hear
mention of the PC Edition Capcom have
said it'll be coming at a later date the
publisher also revealed a brand new
trailer and a $150 collector's edition
that includes a special art box a copy
of the game soundtrack and a physical
action figure of a new monster called
Noda ghonte if you're super excited
about this one and decide to preorder
you'll be able to pick up a bonuses
including the origin set Alma and the
fair wins charm talisman which offer
improved starting defense and offense
stat boosts for the hunter as well as a
useful gathering skill fancy you'll also
get a custom ps4 theme for your trouble
there's also a digital deluxe edition
which retails to 70 bucks and comes with
a bunch of customization options for
your characters which you can check out
in detail in our story on site capcom
has said all of the items will be
available to purchase separately when
the game launches finally overwatch is
next big update is out on all platforms
this update brings a new map and some
significant changes to existing heroes
mercy and diva let's start at the top
the new map is called junker town and is
set here in Australia it's an escort map
so remember to play the payload going
the other major things in this one are
the changes to Mercy her resurrection
ultimate has been completely replaced
by Valkyrie that basically turns her
into the angel of death resurrection has
become an ability now that can work to
get one fall in teammate back in the
battle diva has also undergone some big
changes her defense matrix was proving
too powerful so it's been nerfed but to
help out the Korean future Cup Blizzard
has added a new ability chicken now fire
a barrage of micro missiles while her
suits fusion cannons can now be fired
while flying Reinhardt has also seen a
change in this one as you can now press
primary fire while his shield is
activated to rotate the catwalk now you
can sneak up on Ronnie's honey that is
everything we've got for you guys today
duelist OEE thought of the stories down
in the comment box and remember you can
see our faces every day of the working
week if that's something you want to do
so we will see you tomorrow no giganto
or something or whatever this is like
yesterday with the woods look if you
coulda run a fantasy game called mock
give me a monster named mark Ronald is
this is as far as I'm willing to go for
a complicated to say name all there's
that monster Ronald don't let him come
here I'm not run with the rider I'm
saying like if you are right Oh